salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
si je vous dis bataille d'Alésia Accor
au pluriel des mots se terminant en ou
poser une division évidemment ça vous
parle mais quand il s'agit d'entrer dans
le détail ça coince un peu ce sont
pourtant des savoirs que nous avons
acquis en 6e alors aujourd'hui on va
faire un petit moment de passer retour
au collège en classe de 6e pour revoir
ses savoirs fondamentaux
c'est l'heure je me dépêche
jamais au tableau
bijoux caillou chou genou hibou je joue
et poux ça vous rappelle quelque chose
c'est sept mots en ou sont des
exceptions au pluriel ils ne prennent
pas un S comme les autres mots en ou
mais un X je sais le français est une
langue compliquée pleine d'exception qui
nous pourrissent un peu la vie à croire
que c'est fait exprès pour qu'on a de
mauvaises notes en dictées pas du tout
ça s'explique revenons à nos mots en ou
pour les mémoriser mon prof de français
le vôtre aussi sans doute nous avait
soufflé un petit truc assez pratique une
petite phrase vous l'avez peut-être
encore en mémoire ça faisait viens mon
chou mon bijou sur mes genoux prend ce
caillou pour joujou et jette-le sur ce
hibou plein de poux la leçon n'allait
pas plus loin on nous expliquait
rarement pourquoi ces mots prenaient un
X au pluriel mais bon vous ne connaissez
un peu je suis bien naturel curieux
alors j'ai posé la question à mon prof
et comme c'était une super prof elle
nous a donné la réponse il se trouve
qu'à l'origine chou hibou caillou et les
autres prenez un s au pluriel comme tous
les autres mots en haut c'est au
Moyen-Âge que ça change à cette époque
l'imprimerie n'existe pas encore ce sont
des moines qui se chargent de recopier
les textes à la main sur des grimoires
c'est fastidieux surtout quand il s'agit
de gros ouvrages alors pour gagner du
temps et éviter d'avoir trop mal au
poignet les ecclésiastiques trouvent une
parade ils utilisent des abréviations
pour certains mots se terminant par U et
s au pluriel il se sert d'une
abréviation latine le Oum le
US ça fait Oum là il y a un truc qui
m'échappe hibou au pluriel par exemple
devient hibou écrit de cette manière
mais regardez bien ce symbole que l'on
appelle esperluette ressemble un peu à X
cette similitude va induire les moines
en erreur certains vont involontairement
truquer le esperluette au profit du X
pour une raison inconnue la faute ne
portera que sur 7 mots nos fameux bijoux
cailloux choux etc et c'est ainsi que
hibou écrit de cette manière devient
eBox caillou caillots sauf que pour
garder le son ou de hibou au singulier
et bien on décide finalement de remettre
le U entre le haut et le X et voilà
comment on obtient le pluriel hibou avec
un X et puis avec le temps et bien c'est
cette orthographe qui est entré dans les
dictionnaires bon les jours de dictée il
n'y a pas qu'avec les mots se terminant
en ou qu'on s'arrachait les cheveux pneu
et bleu par exemple sont les deux seuls
mots se terminant par e
U qui prennent un s au pluriel et non
pas un X comme les autres je vous faire
un aveu en 6e je n'étais pas le premier
en dictée mais aujourd'hui ça va
beaucoup mieux et j'espère que pour vous
aussi c'est le cas chouette c'est la
récré non c'est le signal que l'on passe
à une autre matière l'histoire
Alésia ce nom vous dit quelque chose je
sais je sais c'est le nom d'une station
de métro à Paris c'est surtout le nom
d'une grande bataille qui a opposé les
Romains au Gaulois ah mais oui nos
ancêtres les Gaulois cette histoire
débute en 59 avant Jésus-Christ au
passage le casque gaulois avec des ailes
ça n'a jamais existé c'est une pure
invention cette année-là Jules César
était élu au poste de consul c'est la
plus haute charge de la République
romaine et ce titre lui donne des ailes
à lui il veut mettre le monde à ses
pieds et décide d'envoyer ces légions en
Gaule pour agrandir son empire mais pour
y parvenir il doit mater les Gaulois ce
peuple que l'on dit fier et courageux
vit sur d'immens territoire à cheval
entre ce que sont aujourd'hui la France
et la Belgique mais les Gaulois ont un
point faible les nombreux tribus passent
leur temps à se faire la guerre César
comprend très vite le parti qu'il peut
en tirer
revient scientifiques à rallier un
certain nombre de clans à sa cause
tandis que d'autres décident de faire de
la résistance les plus irréductibles se
nomment les Arvernes ils occupent un
territoire qui correspond à laquelle
ovaire il se soulève en 54 avant
Jésus-Christ sous l'impulsion d'un
guerrier dont vous n'avez pas pu oublier
le nom
Vercingétorix qui parvient à vaincre les
légions romaines
à Gergovie en 52 avant Jésus-Christ
César a perdu la bataille mais il n'a
pas dit son dernier mot les Gaulois sont
retranchés dans un oppidum il s'agit
d'une ville fortifiée située sur une
colline dans laquelle Bourgogne son nom
Alésia César qui ne renonce jamais fait
alors parler son génie militaire il
assiège la place en construisant une
double ligne de fortification l'une pour
empêcher Vercingétorix de sortir l'autre
pour empêcher les renforts d'arriver
jusqu'à Alésia les Gaulois sont pris au
piège ils n'ont d'autre choix que de se
rendre Vercingétorix est emprisonné il
va croupir durant 6 ans dans les jours
le romanes avant de passer l'arme à
gauche sans doute exécuter sur ordre de
César allez on va maintenant faire un
tour dans un endroit où il n'y a
vraiment personne enfin à ma
connaissance on part dans l'espace
ça vous étonne si je vous dis qu'en 6e
j'aimais beaucoup les sciences et la
techno vous le savez le système solaire
se compose d'une étoile le Soleil autour
duquel gravite des planètes 8 au total
regardez nous sommes ici à environ 150
millions de kilomètres du Soleil de la
planète la plus proche à la plus
éloignée du soleil on trouve donc bien
sûr Vénus la Terre Mars qui sont des
planètes telluriques autrement dit des
planètes constituées de roches puis
Jupiter Saturne
Uranus et Neptune qui sont des planètes
gazeuses autrement dit des planètes
constituées de gaz pour les retenir dans
l'ordre voici une petite astuce que
notre prof de sixième nous avait soufflé
et que j'utilise encore il suffit de
retenir une phrase ma vieille tortue
Micha joue sur une nappe regardez la
première lettre de chaque mot correspond
à la première lettre de chaque planète
la plus petite planète du système
solaire c'est mercure elle est trois
fois plus petite que la Terre et la plus
grosse c'est Jupiter elle est 11 fois
plus grosse que la Terre à une époque on
apprenait qu'il y avait 9 planètes pas
huit c'est vrai c'est ce que j'ai appris
moi aussi à mon époque pluton était
considéré comme la neuvième planète du
système solaire c'est une toute petite
planète dont la surface totale équivaut
approximativement à la surface de la
Russie mais en 2006 l'Union Astronomique
intern nationale a déclassé Pluton on a
considéré qu'elle ne répondait plus aux
critères officiels qui définissent une
planète pour qu'un astre soit considéré
comme une planète il doit être plus ou
moins sphérique c'est bien le cas de
Pluton il doit tourner autour du soleil
c'est toujours le 4 Pluton il doit avoir
nettoyé le voisinage de sonorbit
autrement dit les corps célestes qui se
trouvaient dans les parages ont été
aspirés en quelque sorte à cause de la
gravité par la planète en question or il
se trouve que Pluton est entouré de
corps célestes qui font quasiment sa
taille et qui tourne justement sur son
orbite Pluton n'est donc plus considéré
comme une planète mais comme une planète
naine c'est une catégorie intermédiaire
entre planète et petit corps du système
solaire
pour une fois que j'avais la bonne
réponse bon ce déclassement fait encore
débat aujourd'hui les scientifiques
américains estiment que Pluton n'aurait
jamais dû être exclu il faut dire que
c'est la seule planète qu'ils ont
découvertes alors vous le savez les
planètes ne sont pas les seules astres
qui peuplent le système solaire il y a
aussi leur satellite certains
ressemblent à des planètes comme deux
gouttes d'eau mais il ne tourne pas
autour du Soleil toutes les planètes du
système solaire en possèdent à
l'exception de mercure et de Vénus
Jupiter en compte 79 Saturne 82 et la
terre un seul il s'agit bien sûr de la
lune en sixième j'y étais souvent dans
la lune moi aussi ça m'arrivait de temps
en temps on passe aux maths on va faire
un peu de calcul
[Musique]
/ 6
=
69,3 avec un smartphone ça prend deux
secondes quand j'étais en 6e on avait
déjà des petites calculatrices à la
maison au collège nous n'avions pas le
droit de nous en servir dommage mais au
fait êtes-vous encore capable de faire
une division à la main comme à l'école
on essaie Jamy au tableau on commence
par tracer deux traits comme ceci un
vertical et l'autre horizontal
perpendiculaire au premier ensuite on
pose le nombre à diviser ici à gauche du
trait on va prendre le nombre 212
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dividende et
on va le diviser par 8 au dessus de la
barre horizontale c'est le diviseur on
commence par se demander combien de fois
le premier chiffre du dividende à savoir
deux comprendre de 8 évidemment c'est
impossible puisque 2 est plus petit
cuites deux plus petits cuites quel est
le mec alors on prend les deux premiers
chiffres du dividende 21 en 21 combien y
a-t-il de fois 8 3 x 8 24 c'est trop
grand deux fois deux fois 8 16 ça
fonctionne on pose le 2 2 x 8 16
et là on fait une petite soustraction 21
- 16 il reste 5 dans 21 il y a bien deux
fois huit plus 5 ensuite on descend le 2
on continue dans 52 combien y a-t-il de
fois 8 cette fois 8 56 c'est trop grand
6 x 88 ça fonctionne on fait la
soustraction 52 - 48 il reste 4 si on
veut inconscient entier on s'arrête là
et le résultat est 26 désolé mais moi
j'obtiens 26,5 il s'est planté et je
n'ai pas terminé ici il reste 4 c'est le
reste de la division une division avec
un reste s'appelle une division
euclidienne du nom d'Euclide le grand
mathématicien de la Grèce antique le
résultat de la division euclidienne
s'écrit donc alors de la manière
suivante
mais mon prof ne s'en contentait pas il
exigeait le quotient exact de la
division allez encore un petit effort
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
212 c'est aussi
212,0 on peut donc poursuivre la
division en descendant ce zéro
mais comme il se trouve après la virgule
on va également rajouter une virgule au
niveau du quotient en 40 combien y
a-t-il de fois 8 là c'est très simple 8
x 5 40
oté de 40 0 le reste est nul et cette
fois ça y est la division est terminée
le résultat de 212 / 8 et donc
26,5 cette fois c'est la récré
alors ce retour en 6e ça a été pas trop
rouillé j'espère que je vous ai
rafraîchi la mémoire et que ça vous a
plu si c'est le cas la prochaine fois on
passe au programme de cinquième vous
savez comment me montrer que vous avez
apprécié ce nouveau format à très
bientôt les épicurioser les épicurieux
[Applaudissements]